- What do we have here?
JOEY: A nice little
Schwinn bike for you.
What do you think?
I think it's seen
its better days.
Obviously, you didn't buy
it new because this thing
is older than you are.
Actually, this thing might
even be older than I am.
[laughter]
Doubt it.
[bell rings]
JOEY: I don't really know
much about the Schwinn bikes.
I know that, back in the
day, they were popular.
I got the bike from my
grandfather's garage.
I picked up the bike
because I wanted
to give it to my girlfriend,
but she looked at it in disgust.
So I figured I'd sell it and
get a couple of dollars for it.
This thing is definitely cool.
Schwinn came out in,
like, the late 1890s,
and they just made
really good bikes.
This came out in,
like, the early '60s.
The Fiesta was, like, their
highest-end girls' bike.
What they were going for
was durability, reliability.
They weren't going for
lightweight, high-speed bike.
Look at modern bikes, like
mountain bikes and stuff
like that.
I mean, they're just
built for speed.
There's no style involved.
This had style.
Schwinn was the iconic
American bicycle brand.
When you thought of bicycles,
first thing you thought out of
was a Schwinn.
Some could go for over $10,000.
It all depends on the model
when it comes to Schwinns.
So what were you
looking to do with it?
I was thinking--
thinking I'd sell
it for a few bucks.
$300, I was looking
for, at least.
Nope.
JOEY: No?
This is the whole thing.
As far as the collector
market goes for bicycles,
it's usually guys, and they
buy the bikes they were
riding when they were kids.
So boys' bikes are
worth a lot more,
and this is a girl's bike.
I can maybe get
this thing restored.
I'm going to show
this to my guy.
And if he can redo this
thing for a decent price,
I'll probably sell
it for $700 or $800,
but I'm hoping he can
do it for $200 or $300.
So I will give you $80.
JOEY: Man.
$250, at least?
No.
I'll tell you what.
I'll give you $100.
I'm not going to go no more.
All right.
I'll give it up for $100.
All right, sweet, man.
JOEY: Appreciate it.
I'm going to take the $100,
give my girlfriend a gift,
and say sorry for
that trashy bike
that I tried to give her before.
I'm hoping I can get it
restored and make a few bucks,
so I've called Bob down
to take a look at it.
This is it.
What do you think?
BOB: It's not in bad shape.
Let's bring it over
here and see if we
can put it up on the table.
Here we go.
It's a Schwinn, so it takes
two people to lift it.
BOB: OK.
First of all, it's a girl's.
And the girls' bicycle
market is really down.
But this was part of
their top of the line.
They had the Debutante, the
Deluxe, and they had this.
It's a cool bike.
So can you fix this thing up?
BOB: Of course I can fix it up.
I can this look great.
With a lot of chrome work.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9--
10 pieces of chrome.
They'll look fabulous
when it's done.
They'll look
absolutely outrageous.
We'll strip down the
whole bike, repaint it,
re-stripe it, replace the seat.
And all that will
cost you only $1,400,
and then you'll be able
to sell it for $700.
[laughter]
So I bought it in mind that
it might be a parts bike,
so apparently it's going
to be a parts bike.
BOB: Oh, yeah.
You'll do a hell
of a lot better.
You know, you've got stuff
like this original rack here,
the original light, the tank.
You should do real well.
You'd do much better
than if you fixed it up.
Well, thanks, Bob.
BOB: Hey, good
luck with it, Rick.
Have fun with it.
That bike would look
bitchin' if we restored it.
It would bring back a
lot of memories for girls
who used to ride that bike.
But at the end result,
it's only worth $700.
If Rick stripped that
down and sold it in parts,
he'd do pretty well.
He could probably make
about $300, $400 on it.
I tried.